people that have stupid amounts of
wealth what's the best way to become
rich
so i actually there's this study i read
again most times i read a study i'm just
like
that's
like i don't believe the study or i'm
like it's like they make these subtle
points you know like if you read any
academic study like usually they're just
like making these very subtle
interactions like theoretical point that
only the researcher you care about but
occasionally you read a a
sentence a study that kind of blows your
mind and i read the studies from the
entire universe of taxpayers american
taxpayers and they analyzed who's in the
top point one percent so it's people
making
uh 1.5 million dollars a year so these
are people approaching the level where
you can't actually just be happy with
how much money you have
and
they said that the typical rich american
is
the owner of a
regional business such as an auto
dealership or beverage distributor
and i read that i'm just like what like
who thinks of an auto dealer owner like
auto dealers just like these annoying
like people with greasy suits who try to
sell us like things we don't need you're
not really thinking of them as like
rich people and then beverage
distributor i didn't even know what that
was uh and
it turns out that
uh so like the the likely so there are a
couple points this one is you have to
own something
to get rich by and large so like if you
look at the richest americans members of
the top point one percent i think about
84 of them are making their money
primarily by owning something not by
paying paid a salary so there are some
people who are just like get paid a ton
of money superstar lawyers maybe or
stuff like that yeah yeah yeah so you
know occasionally but usually if people
are owning something
uh and then
you want to have like some sort of
a good and then you want to go on a good
field so all these fields that are awful
uh they've done studies the quickest
field businesses like that go out of the
business the field where the business
goes out of uh business quickest and
like number one was record store uh the
average record store lasts 2.5 years
uh in comparison the average dentist's
office lasts 19.5 years and basically
the problem is everybody wants to own a
record store they're all these movies
made about record stores uh like there
have been a whole bunch of record store
movies i think probably every time some
that movie comes out everyone's like i'm
going to quit my job and start a record
store and
it's just like not a good path and
like toy store is an awful business
clothing stores awful business
uh uh there's some other ones and
but then there are things you basically
want a local you want a local monopoly
where like so auto dealerships
there they have like legal protections
where you kind of have franchise rights
to service a particular
car company in your local region
and that's a big advantage in business
if you have legal protections about
against some
random person coming in and stealing
your business and i think
now so i think you can't really read
this
this that and say okay now i'll just
start a local dealer i'll now just start
an auto dealership because the whole
point of auto dealership is you're not
allowed to start a new one and compete
with these these people
uh but
uh
i think you want to be thinking in that
principle of like what's my local
monopoly that allows
like that allows me to avoid
someone just
you know stealing my entire business or
offering a lower price or anything and
even i talk about the book that like
independent creatives
may be a better bet than i had thought
uh being kind of like what you're doing
like a podcast host or when i'm doing a
writer
and it's there are like a surprise i was
surprised by how many people
are
entering the top one percent or even the
top point one percent as independent
creatives it's still a long shot most
people aren't
but it's not like
as
big a long shot as i thought and i think
the reason for that is you have a local
monopoly so like
if chris you know as you're building
your brand
you build a fan base
and then like
everybody i could be on 20 different
podcasts well your fans are gonna listen
to your podcast and watch i you can ask
me the same questions you could be like
someone else could be you know should i
play with my pet or
uh have sex and
the exact same questions but you're
gonna have an edge because you've built
a fan base
uh and similarly you know i've written
some books and
people i already have
like people who bought liked everybody
lies my first book and now they're gonna
give me kind of the benefit of doubting
uh don't trust your guts you have you do
have this kind of a little bit of a vote
as a
creative
uh that
like
i think it's a better business than like
pest control or something
or a record store
yeah well record yeah but like even even
some boring businesses like pest control
the data says like basically nobody's
getting rich from pest control
businesses and the problem with being in
the pest control business
is
you don't you're there's no way to build
a local monopoly like you're basically
competing against everybody and
everybody's just googling for pest
control and you have to any profit you
have you're going to give away an
ads
on google to try to get higher up on the
list like nobody's like you know there's
no name in pest control or there's no
there's no legal protection i really
like this seth seth's pest control
because of the personality that he
brings when he's getting rid of my
cockroaches yeah nobody yeah nobody and
and like you don't even have have that
many repeat customers anyway so there's
just like not yeah
yeah it's really hard to escape the
perfect competition that field so like
to say
competition you either need
like a legal protection a legal
protection like all of these dealerships
have
you need
like some sort of personal context being
like really deep in a field what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
oh